yesterday this entire
bogus voter fraud narrative from the
trump campaign
that claims joe biden stole the election
came
to an incredible climax as rudy giuliani
and other trump lawyers
held a press conference in washington dc
that was beyond parody first of all rudy
giuliani appeared to melt during the
event first he was sweating
uncontrollably
and then it looked like he was bleeding
out of both of his ears it actually
apparently was
melting hair dye i mean the optics of
this are absurd
he had what looked like dried blood down
the sides of his face
what reportedly was hair dye that under
the hot lights in the basement of the
rnc or wherever they were was starting
to melt
the content was no more sensible during
the press conference they blamed the
following entities
in part for stealing the election from
donald trump
democrat-run cities democrat mayors
dominion voting systems
here we go now cuba venezuela hugo
chavez
nicolas maduro poll workers election
officials and i'm probably forgetting
some
uh oh george soros which we will get to
no
good right wing conspiracy is complete
until you include a rich jewish man in
it that's almost a requirement at this
point in time
first did they present proof of fraud
they did not just more complaints about
circumstances take a listen
knight seven or eight hundred thousand
in pennsylvania
somehow he lost pennsylvania we have
statisticians willing to testify
that that's almost statistically
impossible to have happen in the period
of time that it happened
but of course that's just speculation
right it is speculation i'm glad rudy
acknowledges that
and it continued which
to any experienced investigator
prosecutor
would suggest that there was a a plan
from a centralized place to execute
these various acts of voter fraud
specifically focused on
big cities and specifically focused on
as you would imagine big cities
controlled by
democrats i don't know guys big
cities controlled by democrats starting
to sound like
shorthand for places with lots of black
people
talking about philadelphia and detroit
and others
then this is real this is not a skit
rudy
reenacted a scene from the film my
cousin vinnie
and then casually accused joe biden's
campaign of committing crimes and fraud
take a look
probably the closest they got is from
here to the back of that room
we could do like a uh did you all watch
my cousin vinnie
did you know the movie it's one of my
favorite war movies
because he comes from brooklyn and when
the the nice lady
who said she saw and then he uh
he says to her how many fingers do i how
many fingers will i got up
and she says uh three
well she was too far away to see it was
only two
these people were further away than my
cousin vinnie
was from the witness they couldn't see a
thing
now i don't know you're going to tell me
that 60 people are lying
they didn't just tell me this they swore
under penalty of perjury
which is something no democrats ever
done so this is probably a good time to
talk about affidavits as evidence versus
affidavits as proof
they talk about the fact that they have
affidavits
as proof that there was fraud really
important to understand this
an affidavit is a form of evidence
which much like testimony from a witness
could be admissible or not depending on
the specifics depending on the court and
the circumstances
sometimes a court will say okay the
we've seen the affidavit
we need to bring in the witness to
actually uh testify to this
in court and an affidavit much like
witness testimony
could be ruled out as hearsay or not
okay so the fact
that affidavits exist
they claim is proof of fraud when it is
not your affidavit
may or may not be used as evidence your
affidavit much like testimony could be
considered by a judge or jury
credible or not credible affidavits are
not proof
all right there are sworn affidavits
about bigfoot
what that means is that an individual is
willing to testify to that
it doesn't mean that the testimony would
necessarily be credible or proof of
anything
rudy then goes on to say that listen
if you don't count wayne county which is
where detroit is in michigan
trump wins that state take a listen to
this in one
80 20. so you see a change as a result
of the of that of the election in in
michigan
if you take out wayne county so it's a
very significant case
now it just so happens that wayne county
has 1.75 million people in it and
michigan's total population is 10
million so what rudy is saying is
if you do for some reason if you were to
not count
a county that has nearly 18 of the
state's population
then the other candidate would win oh
okay that's not how this works though
that's a very strange thing to say
and then rudy giuliani says that they
are looking at potentially trying to
overturn the results
in this long laundry list of states
which and
we have a significant number of
allegations in the state of virginia
i don't know yet whether the number in
virginia will reach the number that can
turn
uh the election in the states that we
have indicated in rhett
georgia pennsylvania michigan wisconsin
nevada and arizona we more than double
the number of votes needed to overturn
the election in terms of
provable illegal ballots all you got to
do
to find out if i'm misleading you at all
is to look at the lawsuit they had a map
up as well with those states in red
delusional then in came sydney powell
who is another one of trump's attorneys
and she this sounded like a sean hannity
monologue
talking about take the country back
because trump won
to know right now that we will not be
intimidated
american patriots are fed up with the
corruption from the local level
to the highest level of our government
and we are going to take this country
back we are not going to be intimidated
we are not going to back down
we are going to clean this mess up now
president trump won by a landslide we
are going to prove it
and we are going to reclaim the united
states of america for the
people who vote for freedom this is a
lawyer
supposedly take the country back
trump won by a landslide this is insane
and then it got really wild another
lawyer jenna ellis took the mic
and she started attacking the media for
how they were going to report
on this completely unhinged event take a
look at this and i'm the senior legal
advisor
uh to the trump campaign and i'd like to
just explain now
uh where we've been and where we're at
and what you can expect from this
process
so what you have heard i'm sure in the
fake newspapers tomorrow will be one of
two things
either there was not sufficient evidence
that we've presented or
we spoke too long okay so what you've
heard
now isn't basically an opening statement
this
is what you can expect to see when we
get to
court to actually have a full trial on
the merits
to actually show this evidence in court
and prove
our case this is not a law and order
episode where everything is neatly
wrapped up in 60 minutes
you know another difference from law and
order episodes is that law and order
episodes contain
actual crimes we still have no evidence
that any crimes took place here
and then when the questions started rudy
giuliani was still melting the hair dye
was just running down his face
looking like he had two ears that were
bleeding and then of course as i said
no good right wing conspiracy theory is
complete until you can include a rich
jewish man in it which rudy did during
the q
a portion of the event talking about
george soros
with a company whose chairman
is a close associate and business
partner of george soros
the biggest donor to the democrat party
the biggest donor to antifa
and the biggest donor to black lives
matter my goodness
what do we have to do to get you to
give our people the truth it always is a
better conspiracy from the standpoint of
the right
if you can pull in a rich jewish man
it's a better conspiracy
and then rudy giuliani caps this off by
saying listen
none of us are engaging in fantasy but
trump
actually won pennsylvania pennsylvania
and michigan
i don't know what you need to wake you
up
to do your job and inform the american
people
whether you like it or not of the things
they need to know
this is real it is not made up it is not
there's nobody here
that engages in fantasies i've tried 100
cases
i prosecuted some of the most dangerous
criminals in the world
i know crimes i can smell them you don't
have to smell this one
i can prove it to 18 different ways i
can prove to you
that he won pennsylvania by 300 000
votes
i can prove to you that he won michigan
by probably 50 000 votes
no fantasies here guys just rudy
claiming
trump won states that trump obviously
lost some say this is merely sad
reportedly rudy is charging 20 grand a
day to represent trump
so if he's actually getting paid that
trump has a reputation for not paying
people that work for him
rudy is making a fool out of himself yes
but he's potentially being compensated
quite handsomely parodies of themselves
how do you make a satire of that if you
are saturday night live
you can't let me know what your thoughts
are i'm on twitter at deepakman
i'm really excited that uh one of our
sponsors today
is helix sleep i sleep on a helix
mattress
at home i absolutely love it and that's
why
i reached out to them about sponsoring
the david pakman show
buying a mattress in the past was always
a huge guessing game for me
i didn't know what i actually needed i
didn't know what i would like
but helix has a sleep quiz on their
website you tell them your body type
your sleeping position
your back pain issues you might have and
their
tool matched me with a mattress that is
perfect for me
it's cool enough at night it's the right
firmness
i generally just do way better sleeping
these days because of the mattress helix
was awarded
number one best overall mattress for the
last two years
by both gq and wired magazine it is well
deserved i can tell you firsthand
every helix mattress comes with a 10
year warranty
you can try the mattress risk free for
100 nights
and they will even come pick it up at
your house if you don't love it
but i know you will all of my viewers
will get up to 200
off your order and you'll get two super
premium
pillows for free when you go to the link
right underneath this video